hey guys preview for the final episode
of the season just dropped and he once
again confirms that this episode will be
one of the best episodes of the series
before I break down this preview let me
just say that part two of leaked review
for the seventh episode will be
published tomorrow so make sure you stay
tuned for that if you like spoilers
anyways as expected this previous is all
about a huge meeting that will take
place in the dragon pit now that John
and his team managed to capture white
with Danny's help their next goal is to
persuade all the lords queens and kings
to send her army snort so they could
stand a chance against the night king
and his army of the Dead they will try
to do so by bringing a captured white
and proving them that the threat is real
and that the Great War is not coming any
more but his rather here as just said
himself we see the unsullied and a
Trekkie being placed outside King's
Landing doors which later amazes Jaime
and Bronn who oversee King's Landing
defenses the nurse is bringing her
armies in case that Cersei has a trap
for her
in the last episode while taking into
consideration that Jon and team might
manage to capture white and bring into
King's Landing
whereupon they all would have a huge
meeting Tyrion said that if they are to
go to the capital they're bringing two
armies and dragons Daenerys bringing her
forces and placing them outside King's
Landing doors is ensuring that Cersei
will not harm Danny in any way otherwise
the capital would burn down to the
foundation stones as I've already said
invitation for this huge meeting was
sent to everyone including their worst
enemies including your own Greyjoy
additionally their worst enemy Circe is
the main reason they went beyond the
wall to capture white so they could
prove to her as well as to the whole
Westeros that they must stop fighting
among themselves since the only word
that matters is in the north and they
need every single person in order to
stand a chance against that enemy as you
can see in a few shots everyone is
arriving at Dragonstone together Jonny's
arriving with his team as well as with
Danny's team Cersei on the other hand is
arriving at Jaime and most probably with
Qyburn and urine as well but the only
person we don't see is the mother of
dragons then it will most certainly
attend this meeting and she will most
probably arrive on top of Dragoon
accompanied with regal beside being
quite obvious since she's mother of
dragons
there's also unseen from the previous
season that pretty much confirms this in
the sixth episode of the previous season
bran had a vision image among all the
other shots we also get to see one
particular shot that provided us a
shadow of a dragon flying above King's
Landing
anyways spree
hence with John trying to come in sir
see that the only word that matters is
the one against the night King John is
trying to persuade serfs in descending
her troops north but its outcome is
questionable they prove to her that the
army of the Dead is real but will it
truly make Cersei to support fight
against it or will it rather make a rule
for the night king to destroy our
enemies remains to be seen among gold Oh
shots from King's Landing and the dragon
pet there's also a shot from inter fell
in Rankin stone in Winterfell sense is
about to do something of great
importance which I'm not revealing in
this video because it's a huge spoiler
but will be included in the video that I
published tomorrow on the shores of
Dragonstone theme really the remaining
Ironborn and formed a rescue party
heading out to save Yara in conclusion
the final episode of the season will
contain some major events and will
probably be the best episode yet
produced